Do you recommend repeating a Dutch test periodically?
Absolutely, because, well, your cortisol level is going
to change, and I will say this, if you're going to do a cortisol
test, either through the Dutch test or the adrenal stress profile,
you really have to do it on a day that's a normal day.
Because if your normal is fairly in your mind, fairly
stress-free, but then you had a super stressful day.
And it's going to show.
And then on that day, you do the adrenal stress profiles.
It's not going to be a real test.
So you want to do what you would consider your normal day.
It might be very stressful.
But if that's, if you're under a lot of stress all the time,
you want to know what your cortisol levels are on an average time.
So if it was just a day full of stress,
and you run it, then you lose the value of it.
So you lose them out because your cortisol levels
are going to go up and down, depending on your stress levels.
Your cortisol is released by your adrenal glands
and functions on many different levels.
And at one of the levels, it's a breakdown
like it in stores.